hi this is Jeremy Lin I'm here at
bleacher report we are in Seattle at the
dota internationals we're going to go
downstairs in a sec talk to some people
and see what's up who you dressed up as
when running you don't make a decision
here can you elaborate on that
I had like about $60 left this was 15 so
I bought it that's like most of my
studying like on $60 in your savings or
$60 like on the to the money that you're
giving yourself to spend the money that
my parents gave me Justin I couldn't
help but notice your outfit can you give
us your name and the reason for your
outfit ah mines tubes and these are just
really really comfortable shorts in the
shoes they're just really really
comfortable shoes can you explain to me
what's dangling around your neck hi this
is a plush its invoker would you say
it's accurate to say that you look
slightly like invoker I don't think so
he has like long luscious blonde hair I
don't know I don't know if I fit that
profile and you are dressed up as the
character Omni Knight from the game and
why Omni Knight it all started whenever
I was number 5 on the top 100 on the
knight bracket so I guess that's that's
the main reason why
but I like him because he's sort of one
of the best characters in the game even
though it's not being picked
you know the cash prize is twenty
million dollars this is hypothetically
say you get twenty million dollars today
what would you do with it pay off all my
student loans you have twenty million
dollars in student loans oh no I got to
talk to you I got to talk to you for
sure explain what your thinking your
thought process always wanted braids do
always come in here decide to get them
yeah first time I've ever had braids
yeah what do you what do you think about
the tournament so far oh it's been great
I mean this is probably the most
unpredictable TI we've ever seen in
terms of results so I'm having a great
time very cool and I'm assuming the game
from yesterday one of the best dota
games of all time most likely eg vs.
eHome game one that was that's something
to remember for sure would you say it is
the best for one of the best I would say
one of the best for the time that it
happened yeah you got to run other you
go KC can we interview you can we crash
your interview with our interview can
you describe what you are currently
dressed at this I am dressed up as
timbersaw last year I said I'm going to
cosplay timbersaw and they said you need
to do it early and I said whatever and
then in June of this year I went to
valve and said so if I were to cosplay
timbersaw what do I do and they say well
you need to rewind time and start over
again because we can't do it and I said
okay fine so into the costume shop and I
went to Northwest art and frame in West
yellow and I went to the toy store for
these and I put my own thing together
you know you don't seem like somebody I
want to mess with so yeah you got it
thank you for following us today we
talked the game we talked the cash prize
we talked cosplay we talked hair we
talked pretty much everything there is
to talk about so thank you again for
watching I'm gonna go watch some indie
games now hopefully you guys enjoyed
this interview and enjoy the rest of Ti